[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
au sommaire aujourd'hui la birmanie ou
un coup d'état militaire met fin à une
fragile parenthèse démocratique ouverte
il y à une décennie de changement de
pouvoir la détention donc sommesous qui
est la répression des manifestations de
la part des militaires risque d'avoir un
fort impact sur l'échiquier régional
quel est donc l'ampleur de la crise
politique en birmanie
la mobilisation contre le coup d'état
sententiae fit des centaines de milliers
de personnes continuent à descendre dans
la rue pour exiger la libération de la
dirigeante civil birman aung san suu kyi
afin de disperser les manifestants la
police a eu recours à la force au 10
mars en birmanie selon les nations unies
on compte 67 morts et des centaines de
blessés la plupart des pays occidentaux
regard d'un mauvais oeil la prise de
pouvoir par les militaires
les etats unis le royaume uni
l'australie recours à des sanctions la
chine au contraire refuse de qualifier
ces événements de coups d'état et
bloquent la déclaration du conseil de
sécurité condamnant le changement de
pouvoir afin de tracer la voie vers la
sortie de crise l'an denaisis en dos
activement le rôle de médiateur elle
organise une rencontre trilatérale entre
les ministres des affaires étrangères
birman thaïlandais et indonésien à
bangkok
pourtant ces résultats sont plus que
limités alors que l'opposition birmane
accusent la chine de complicité avec les
militaires
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le système politique birman
de l'avant coup d'état c'est le blitz la
pierre angulaire de la structure
politique birmane et la constitution
adoptée en 2008
elle prévoit un partage des pouvoirs
entre un gouvernement civil et les
généraux du pays un compromis entre
l'ancien état de choses est le
changement libéral voulue par le peuple
ainsi que les pressions internationales
en vertu de ce document l'armée conserve
un rôle important dans les institutions
politiques
elle dispose d'un quart des sièges dans
les deux chambres du parlement soit une
représentation suffisantes pour empêcher
tout changement de la constitution
les militaires se réserve en outre le
droit de nommer trois ministres clés
dans le gouvernement
ceux de la défense de l'intérieur des
frontières
théoriquement le rôle de chef de l'état
revient au président or de fait ces
dernières années le pouvoir réel était
détenu par hong sang soo qui ministre
des affaires étrangères est conseillère
d'état symbole de la lutte contre la
dictature militaire et prix nobel de la
paix elle a passé près de 15 ans en
détention avant de réaliser un retour
spectaculaire dans la vie politique en
remportant les élections législatives de
2015 une victoire qui ne lui a tout de
même pas permis de briguer un mandat
présidentiel
car la constitution barre la route à la
présidence à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont mariés à un étranger voici plus
d'un mois que la birmanie est secoué par
une contestation populaire sans
précédent
des centaines de milliers de personnes
protestent quasi quotidiennement contre
le renversement du gouvernement au civil
donc sont ceux qui par les militaires
qui depuis ne font qu'attiser la colère
de la rue
il déclare l'état d'urgence pour un an
et annuler les résultats des élections
législatives de 2020 remportées par le
parti de l'ex dirigeante birmane
afin de disperser la foule armée recours
à la force
bilan au moins 67 morts des centaines de
blessés et plus de 1700 arrestation le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu adopte à
l'unanimité une résolution condamnant
les violences
la majorité de la communauté
internationale reconnaît l'issue de ce
scrutin elle s'oppose fermement à la
prise de pouvoir par l'armée
la chine elle estime que tout cela
relève des affaires internes de la
birmanie l'indonésie elle s'impose de
plus en plus en tant que médiateur parmi
ceux qui pourraient peser dans la crise
actuelle berman figurent la chine l'inde
et la russie
tous les trois ont d'importants intérêts
politiques et économiques dans ce pays
et maintiennent de bonnes relations avec
l'armée ainsi qu'avec le camp civile
alors comment le coude et en birmanie
petit l'affecté l'échiquier régional
pourquoi la médiation indonésienne
n'at-elle rien donné quels sont les
premiers pas du nouveau gouvernement
birman à l'international pour répondre à
toutes ces questions nous rejoignons
olivier guillard chercheur au ceri assez
directeur de l'information chez garda
world
monsieur guillard bonjour tout d'abord
parlons des parties en conflit en
birmanie il ya d'un côté donc ce qui est
les militaires de l'autre est ce que les
militaires tiennent la responsabilité
totale de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans le pays oui dans une très bonne
mesure puisque les militaires sont à
l'origine donc dû lutter pour nos
auditeurs dont contre dirigé le pays
d'une main de fer entre 1962 et 2010
2011 d'une manière extrêmement rude avec
des épisodes de répression assez
régulier avec des lits une lutte de tous
les instants pour ralentir les interros
démocratique de la population en le 1er
février donc dernier l'armée a décidé
quasiment alors même que le parlement
issu du dernier scrutin qui est
largement une fois encore été remporté
par les forces démocratiques devait
tenir sa séance inaugurale les
militaires ou considérés ils l'ont déjà
fait par le passé que le résultat des du
vote n'était pas bon que d y est que le
scrutin a été entaché de fraudes un peu
comme nous avons pu voir outre
atlantique et quelques moyens et qu'en
définitive dans que la constitution
devait être observée est appliqué un
immunitaire qui ont trouvé donc cet
argument aussi fallacieux que le déni de
toute preuve tangible pour revenir au
pouvoir aujourd'hui
donc si nous avons une soixantaine de 70
victimes hormis les deux personnes
arrêtées et des centaines et des
milliers de blessés en birmanie
cette birmanie pro démocratie très
largement c'est évidemment largement le
fait de la de la junte militaire du
général qu'il pays selon vous pourrait
aujourd'hui jouer le rôle de médiateur
dans cette crise avec qui les militaires
eux sont prêts à négocier
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde qui se
présente pour faire de la médiation dont
ceux dans ce conflit ouvert entre deux
pans tagetik de la société il y a les
voisins certainement aux pays asiatiques
nous avons la chine au nord nous avons
éventuellement l'inde reste
la thaïlande sur le flanc oriental du
pays peut faire également de la
médiation sur le sujet nous avons
également au delà d'autres acteurs
asiatiques qui ont leur mot à dire
notamment les investisseurs étrangers
qui sont très présents dans le pays
on pensait là pour le coup à singapour
mais également et surtout à la japon
principaux donateurs
l'assisteur tête du latéral
d'investissements directs étrangers
l'ennui c'est que les militaires ne
veulent entendre personne et qu'il s'en
faire entre guillemets dans logiquement
se disant que l'on définitive même si
quelques news international soutient
nouveau en pro démocratie et donc
condamne leurs actions malfoy l'action
ou les sanctions que pourrait définir la
communauté internationale sont
relativement indolore et être relève
simplement du financier et de
l'administratif ce qui n'a jamais fait
trembler les généraux birmans jusqu'à ce
jour
donc cette médiation là
cette offre de médiation il ya également
des offres de médiation d'organisations
internationales et onusiennes notamment
vont européenne à un certain niveau les
militaires ne veulent guère en entendre
parler
donc c'est déjà pratiquement couper
court à une possibilité de sortie crise
en la médiation ce qui rend faire encore
des deux parties dans une logique de
confrontation qui devrait perdurer et
probablement donc se sait ce qu'elle
veut des sept prochains jours ces
prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup monsieur guillard nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de l'émission pour plus de détails
sur ce thème merci encore coupure
d'internet déploiement massif des forces
de l'ordre vague d'arrestations et tirs
à balles réelles
la birmanie est de nouveau contrôlé par
les militaires
dès début février des centaines de
milliers de personnes descendent dans la
rue pour protester contre le coup d'état
militaire
brandissant des pancartes en soutien à
l'ex dirigeante birmane aung san suu kyi
les manifestants exigent sa libération
la réponse de l'armée est sévère elle
restreint l'accès à facebook
whatsapp instagram et twitter et
intensifie l'usagé de la force
gaz lacrymogènes canons à eau balles en
caoutchouc et parfois à balles réelles
le 3 mars est la journée la plus
meurtrière depuis le début de la
contestation
au moins 38 personnes ont été tuées dans
les heurts avec la police
le bilan total s'élève aujourd'hui à 67
morts selon les nations unies
des centaines de personnes ont été
blessées au moins 1700 arrêté alors
comment les militaires se sont ils à
nouveau accaparé du pouvoir en birmanie
tout commence par le scrutin législatif
organisé en novembre 2020 en vertu de la
constitution
les militaires se réserve
automatiquement 25% des sièges dans les
deux chambres du parlement
lyon aussi un allié le parti de l'union
de la solidarité et du développement
or celui ci connaît un échec cuisant il
n'obtient que 26 sièges sur 440 dans la
chambre basse est sept sièges sur 224
dans la chambre haute du parlement
en revanche la ligue nationale pour la
démocratie donc son dessous qui remporte
une victoire écrasante et gagne 83 % des
mandats encore plus qu'en 2015
un véritable désastre pour les généraux
qui conteste ce résultat
quelques jours avant l'entrée en
fonction du nouveau parlement l'armée
affirme avoir recensé 8 6 millions de
cas de fraudes et demandé le recomptage
de tous les bulletins la commission
électorale ni ces allégations mais
reconnaît tout de même des défauts dans
les listes électorales 287 plaintes sont
en cours de traitement
une goutte dans l'océan qui n'en
florence rey aucunement l'issue du
scrutin le 1er février l'armée passe à
l'offensive
la chef d'état on retombe sous qui le
président win min ainsi que plusieurs
dizaines de hauts fonctionnaires sont
arrêtés lors des raids effectués tôt le
matin dans la capitale naypyidaw le
vice-président mais ils souhaient
membres du parti de l'union de la
solidarité et du développement devient
président par intérim et transfère les
pleins pouvoirs au chef de l'armée qui
proclame l'état d'urgence pour un an et
dissous le parlement
il promet d'organiser de nouvelles
élections une fois que l'état d'urgence
sera levé la commission électorale
réformé devrait superviser le scrutin
alors de quoi en dessous qui est elle
accusée au juste les autorités actuelles
lui reproche d'avoir acheté est importé
illégalement si talkie walkie un acte
qui viole deux lois nationales à la fois
celle sur l'import export et celle sur
les télécommunications
ensuite
accusation de violation des règles
sanitaires car l'ex dirigeante birmane a
mené sa campagne en pleine pandémie
elle est en outre accusé d'incitation à
des troubles publics en mars 2021 l'ex
dirigeante birmane est accusée de
corruption selon l'armée il aurait
touché des paiements illégaux d'une
valeur de 600 mille dollars durant ses
années au pouvoir
la majorité de la communauté
internationale appelle à sa libération
immédiate et à la cessation des
violences le 10 mars le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu adopté à l'unanimité
une résolution condamnant fermement
l'usagé de la force à l'égard des
manifestants et appelant l'armée birmane
à la retenue
même le secrétaire général de l'onu qui
d'habitude évite de prendre parti dans
les différends internes tient des propos
virulents à l'égard de l'armée birmane
nous ferons tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour mobiliser tous les acteurs
clés et la communauté internationale
afin qu'ils exercent une pression
suffisante sur la birmanie et que ce
coup d'état échoué
cette position est partagée par la
plupart des pays occidentaux
l' approche la plus dure est adoptée par
les états unis 1 1 mois washington
adopte deux volets de sanctions à
l'égard de nouvelles autorités birmanes
le 11 février dix personnes supposément
impliqués dans le coup d'état ainsi que
trois entreprises birmanes liés aux
militaires se retrouvent sur la liste
noire américaine
tous leurs avoirs basée aux etats-unis
sont gelés
l'autre mesure prévoit le blocage d'un
milliard de dollars de fonds guerman
dans les banques américains quelques
jours plus tard washington ajoutent à
cette liste
deux autres officiers la mesure serait
une réponse à la violence policière à
l'égard des manifestants birman alors
comment ces changements brutaux en
birmanie peuvent-ils changer le paysage
géopolitique de la région où les
nouvelles autorités birmanes
cherche-t-elle du soutien quelles sont
les solutions qui s'offrent pour sortir
pacifiquement de cette crise
la réponse après la pause depuis le coup
d'état perpétré début février la crise
politique ne fait que prendre de
l'ampleur en birmanie des centaines de
milliers de manifestants continuent à
occuper les rues de la capitale
il lance un vrai défi aux militaires qui
ont gouverné le pays pendant des
décennies ancienne colonie britannique
la birmanie est un pays aux assises
fragile car divisé en de nombreuses
ethnies 135 sont recensés officiellement
à cette fracture s'ajoutent les
divisions politiques nés lors des luttes
pour l'indépendance notamment pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale et l'occupation
du pays par les japonais après sa
libération les pays se dirige vers
l'indépendance
les élections d'avril 1947 amène au
pouvoir anc san leader charismatique de
la lutte pour l'indépendance et artisans
de l'union qui promet aux minorités
ethniques une autonomie administrative
cependant le 19 juillet de la même année
il est assassiné ainsi que la plus
grande partie de son gouvernement par un
groupe politique opposé
vide politique ainsi créés se traduisit
par plusieurs insurrection armée
déclenchée par des groupes ethniques et
des factions politiques la birmanie
accède toutefois l'indépendance en 1948
après des débuts difficiles le pays
connaît une période de relative
stabilité politique sous les 2
gouvernements successifs du premier
ministre où nous cependant une mauvaise
politique économique et technique
entraîne dans les années 50 une nouvelle
rébellion des minorités affaibli par une
scission interne à son parti
il est contraint à faire appel à l'armée
en 1958 le général ne win devient
premier ministre par intérim et instaure
une administration militaire provisoire
les élections de février 1960 sont
remportées par la formation de nounous
et les militaires retournent dans leurs
casernes
mécontents de l'action gouvernementale
ils finissent par organiser un coup
d'état pour prendre le pouvoir en 1962
mais wind instant riz dictature
militaire et la création d'un parti
unique le parti du programme socialiste
birman le parlement est dissous
toutes les entreprises sont alors
nationalisé et le pays mal géré et
s'enfonce dans la pauvreté et
l'isolément
le régime tente aussi de négocier avec
les ethnies mais la guérilla reprend dès
1965 en 1974 une nouvelle constitution
est adoptée avec la création d'une
assemblée du peuple à parti unique
cette libéralisation toute relative
conduit les groupes en rébellion à
s'unir au sein d'un front démocratique
national en 1975 le général ne win tente
aussi de lancer un plan de développement
sur 20 ans en espérant attirer les
investissements étrangers
sans résultat l'exacerbation des
problèmes économiques allant jusqu'à des
pénuries de produits de première
nécessité et l'incapacité du
gouvernement à les résoudre
entraîne des émeutes en 1988 devant
l'ampleur de la contestation
le général ne win est finalement
contraint de quitter le pouvoir au
conseil d'état pour le rétablissement de
la loi et l'ordre et mis en place par
les militaires en 1988
cette même année à osan succi fille de
aung sann revient d'exil et font de la
ligue nationale pour la démocratie
ce parti remporte les élections de 1990
mais un nouveau coup d'état militaire
avec une féroce répression bloque la
situation aung san suu kyi est assignée
à résidence
elle reçoit le prix nobel de la paix en
1991 alors que des sanctions
internationales frappe le pays
les nouveaux dirigeants décide alors
d'entamer une timide libéralisation
principalement sur le plan économique au
cours des années 1990 la birmanie
parvient également à développer des
relations diplomatiques et commerciales
avec ses voisins asiatiques notamment la
thaïlande et surtout la chine
elle intègre même la zean en 1997 au
cours des années 2000 des divergences
apparaissent au sein de la junte
militaire certains étant favorables à
une poursuite de la politique
d'assouplissement à osan succi elle
libéré en 2010 le pays entame une lente
démocratisation en 2011 avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir du général times m petit à
petit l'union européenne lève ses
sanctions économiques en 2013 ainsi que
les états unis la birmanie ouvre aux
capitaux étrangers certains pans de son
économie
jusqu alors essentiellement et attiser
les élections législatives de 2015
consacre la victoire du parti de hossam
succi avec un soutien massif des
minorités ethniques elle même devient
chef du gouvernement
l'armée garde cependant la mainmise sur
les ministères clés de la défense de
l'intérieur et des affaires frontalières
house and soul qui entame une difficile
réforme de la constitution tout en
négociant avec les militaires sa
réputation à l'international est
cependant terni en 2016 par la crise des
rolling à cette minorité musulmane issue
du bengale est envoyé comme main
d'oeuvre bon marché en birmanie autant
de l'administration coloniale
bien que les réformes économiques et
sociales tarde à se concrétiser et que
le conflit ethnique dur les élections de
novembre 2020 voit la victoire écrasante
de la ligue nationale pour la démocratie
le parti d'aung san suu kyi
aujourd'hui les dirigeants militaires
est quasiment isolée sur la scène
globale
le premier contact international du
nouveau pouvoir birman a lieu trois
semaines après le coup d'état le 24
février le nouveau ministre birman des
affaires étrangères wunna maung lwin
rencontre à bangkok c'est homologue
thaïlandais et indonésien
nous avons demandé que toutes les
parties fassent preuve de retenue et ne
recourt pas à la violence pour éviter
des victimes et l'effusion de sang
la sécurité et le bien-être du peuple
bien mon doivent être se protéger leurs
voeux doivent être entendus une
rencontre dont les détails resteront
derrière les coulisses mais c'est
pourtant la seule avancée tangible vers
le dialogue
habitué à jouer les arbitres dans la
région comme dans les années 80 pour le
cambodge ou encore en 2017 sur la crise
des rohingya jakarta sans pause dans la
solution du conflit birman mi-février la
chef de la diplomatie indonésienne retno
marsudi part en tournée de la région
brunet singapour et d'autre le but est
de pousser la séan a engagé une
médiation en birmanie l'idée est
soutenue par le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu la chine l'union européenne et les
etats unis
parallèlement l'indonésie maintient des
contacts avec les membres du parlement
birman destituer une campagne autour
d'un projet bien concret
d'après reuters l'indonésie aurait
préparé en plan d'action pour la séan
sur la birmanie selon el hassiane doit
servir de médiateur entre le
gouvernement militaire et le mouvement
civil obliger la junte à tenir de
nouvelles élections dans un an et
déployer les observateurs pour assurer
son équité néanmoins ce projet tombe à
l'eau car il déplaît à la rue 'l'annonce
d'une prochaine visite de diplomate
indonésien à naypidaw fait enrager les
opposants sur twitter les activistes
locaux affirment qu elle équivaudrait à
la reconnaissance de la gente militaire
même colère face au plan de jakarta sur
les nouvelles élections le 23 février
des centaines de manifestants se
rassemblent devant l'ambassade
d'indonésie à yangon ils disent un non
ferme à de nouvelles élections exige
d'honorer les résultats du vote de
novembre face à cette réaction
l'indonésie recul elle annule la visite
de sa ministre et désavoue le projet du
nouveau scrutin
du coup l'implication de la séan dans le
règlement birmanie reste hypothétique
comme d'ailleurs celle de la chine
pourtant la confiance de la rue est
minimale dans la position l'axis de
pékin vis-à-vis des événements en bien
manier les oppose on voit un signe de sa
complicité ils en trouvent rapidement
d'autres preuves sur les réseaux sociaux
non confirmées et des théories se
propage à vitesse éclair la chine
construire est la grande muraille
électronique en birmanie à la demande de
l'armée ou encore des vols secrets
transporterait en cachette des soldats
et de l'équipement chinois en birmanie
dans la rue le sentiment antichinois
monter les slogans se multiplient
presque chaque jour des milliers de
manifestants se rassemblent devant
l'ambassade de chine à yangon est en
ligne
des activistes birman appel au boycott
des produits chinois
en effet la chine aurait-elle quelque
chose à gagner du changement de régime
ce n'est pas si évident que ça en effet
dans les années 2000 les relations de
pékin avec le pouvoir militaire birman
se dégrade
longtemps il
sur la scène internationale avec la
chine comme seul allié
les généraux décide alors de s'émanciper
de pékin is annuler plusieurs projets
controversés chinois en birmanie comme
une centrale hydroélectrique ou une
ligne ferroviaire
parallèlement il tente de diversifier
leurs partenaires commerciaux
cependant sous hong sang-soo qui la
température repart à la hausse en 2010
est la birmanie adhère au projet chinois
de la nouvelle route de la soie
du coup la chine commence de nouveau à
développer les infrastructures berman
elle construit un port et une zone
économique spéciale et pense à
redémarrer les projets annulés
en gros la coopération fleury rien qu'en
2020 plus de 30 accords économiques sont
signés en effet pour pékin la birmanie
est un allié stratégique
les infrastructures en construction
doivent donner à la chine
l'accès à l'océan indien enfin ans en
plantant un épisode un côté au pakistan
de l'autre la chine peu un cercle et sa
voisine et rivale régional l'inde
conscient du danger new delhi ne restent
pas bouche bée
l'inde courtisent elle aussi la birmanie
et obtient des succès considérables pour
contrer pékin en asie du sud-est en 2014
l'inde lancent la stratégie acte east la
birmanie est donc son pilier clé c'est
le seul pays sud asiatique à partager
une frontière avec l'inde
elle devient donc le centre de ces
projets une autoroute entre l'inde et la
thaïlande
un corridor reliant l'inde à ces
enclaves le port de sites web tous ces
chantiers sont en cours de finalisation
en birman autres domaines de coopération
la sécurité défense de la frontière
comme une opération conjointe et surtout
ventes d'armes
les liens ne cesse de s'intensifier
soucieuse de préserver ses positions
l'inde évite de critiquer le nouveau
pouvoir birman tout comme la russie
puisque pour moscou la birmanie est
devenu un important débouché pour son
industrie de défense la russie est le
deuxième plus grand fournisseur d'armes
à naypidaw après la chine
102 millions de dollars en 2019
d'ailleurs le plus récent contrat entre
deux pays date du 22 janvier
la birmanie commandes les systèmes de
missiles et des drones russe pour mieux
comprendre les forces en action en
birmanie nous rejoignons olivier
guillard chercheur au sérias et
directeur de l'information chez garda
world
monsieur guillard est ce que la birmanie
se retrouvera encore une fois isolé sur
la scène internationale comme l'a déjà
été d'ailleurs dans la deuxième moitié
du 20e siècle
ce qui est sûr c'est que la birmanie
profiter d'une fenêtre d'ouverture aux
deux revolvers tour de l'euro des
concerts partout du monde au moment où
là une transition démocratique s'est
instauré dans le pays au début des
années 2000 2010 par land entre 2010 et
2015 c'était la période d'or si tu peux
faire de cette redécouverte
internationale l'ensemble des acteurs
internationaux se relève à rangoun est
bidon aussi les devoirs et v entre
guillemets matière à développer soit des
parts de marché soit à se rapprocher du
régime birman et quels qu'ils soient
cet hommage a déjà commencent à se faire
mais malheureusement partir de l'été
2010 est quand la crise des rohingya en
art à cannes rappelez vous ces centaines
de milliers de populations minoritaires
fuyant le pays pour aller se réfugier au
bangladesh dans des conditions de dons
de rudesse et de dureté et de et de
christine ans de génocide comme le dit
le les nations unies est donc tout à
fait déplorable
déjà la communauté internationale avec
mon cell retourner le 12 l'occident
notamment devant ce qui se passait en
birmanie les malheureusement donc un peu
moins de quatre ans plus tard cet
heureux de ce retour de la jatte ce
nouveau chapitre marciel et cette chape
de plomb qui est en train de re couvrir
toute la birmanie celle probablement
pendant un certain temps le le cours de
la birmanie sur la scène internationale
les quantités d'acteurs est là qui se
demandent s'ils ne vont pas partir entre
guillemets leur actif leur personnel
expatrié est tout simplement ce qu'ils
ne vont pas couper toute relation
jusqu'à un retour à un fonctionnement
démocratique normal dans ce pays depuis
l'arrêt de la birmanie est reparti
probablement à moins que les choses ne
s'améliorent mais pour l'instant avec en
pointe guère de chances qu'un mois que
le régime birman en reviennent donc être
de première intention
les ailiers de sa population et de la
gestion des 55 millions d'individus
comment ce coup d'état pourrait-il
changer le paysage géopolitique
dans la région où voyez-vous la création
de nouvelles amitiés au contraire de
nouveaux antagonismes lapierre manie
déjà en soi donc passage aux parties sa
position géographique donc c'est un
point de jointure entre les diverses
régions d'asie exactement c'est un point
je vois un tueur géographique entre le
sous continent indien avec l'un de son
flanc ouest avec le vent chinois donc au
nord est avec l'asie du sud est donc ces
trois joueurs une fois sur stratégie qui
est déjà tout à fait particulier les
voisins de l'asie du sud est ce donc
c'est typique il compose l'asian pour
l'instant essaye et que nous ils font
très fréquemment dès qu'une une crise
survient essaie de s'en mêler sans faire
trop chaud en tous les cas sauf s'il
peut critiquer on le leur reproche à
certains essayent d'être un petit peu
plus pour que soit le sujet mais peinent
à se faire entendre
la chine tente un l1 privilégié peu
importe c'est sa politique depuis une
petite douzaine d'années peu importe qui
est au pouvoir dans ceux en birmanie il
faut que la chine qui est il ya des
intérêts économiques et stratégies de
particuliers soient en bon terme avec
alex original et de l'autre côté pour
revenir dans quinze jours
occupation jumeaux stratégique nous
avons l'un qui souffre d'un déficit de
l2 d'affluence dans ce pays important sa
vie donne à la chine il ya des
intéressés stratégie particulier
analystes beaucoup
elle essaie de récupérer un peu de ce
déficit et d'influx ans dans ce pays et
qu'elle a accumulées ces trente
dernières années
donc c'est un point de rivalité
particulier c'est également un point
jeunes de rivalité jeux d'eau sera très
important dans la mesure où il est où
des pyrénées 2000 dif lougheed en
espérait revenir en influençant présence
il y en a l'activité économique et
commerciale dans ce pays pour essayer de
regretter son retard par rapport à la
france prépare la chine
visiblement ça de la crise d'aujourd'hui
a certainement donc amenés à ces
batailles 3 certaine manière et profiter
problème davantage au championnat
portugais
merci beaucoup monsieur guillard je
rappelle olivier guillard chercheurs
osteria c'est directeur de l'information
chez garda world était aujourd'hui avec
nous pour apporter son éclairage merci
beaucoup
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]